and
summer's ending the way it began yeah
the unofficial start of summer memorial
day weekend and we had several
challenging difficult
painful emotional shows
early on
in the aftermath of the george floyd
murder
and
you know
i'm i'm going to get the tweets and i'm
going to get the emails and i'm going to
get the complaints that we're not
talking about football today we're not
talking about sports today and let me
just
quote
washington nationals pitcher sean
doolittle from july the 5th different
context but the same message applies
sports are a reward for
for a functional society talking about
sports is part of that reward
and when
the societal issues
in golf sports that's what we have to
talk about what's going on in sports how
is sports affected by what's going on in
the world now the pandemic was the thing
that made us dysfunctional for
the middle chunk of the summer yep but
early summer late summer we're back
in the same spot we're talking about
social injustice we're talking about
police brutality we're talking about an
unarmed black man shot seven times in
the back when he posed no immediate
threat to police officers it's
astounding to me
and let me apologize in advance we're
gonna veer off from time to time we're
going to share our views we're human
beings we're all human beings we're
trying to process this way through it
and understand it but chris
it's astounding to me that there are
people out there
who
are acting like jacob blake got what he
deserved that in some way it was
justified to shoot him point blank seven
times in the back when he's getting into
a vehicle well he had a knife he may
have had a knife he may have done this
he may have done that look
police officers should not have the
power of judge jury and executioner
right to dispense lethal force and
potentially death and jacob blake is not
dead but by all appearances he is
permanently paralyzed from the waist
down right that is not something that
someone
who
went to the police academy and has 500
hours of training and experience or
whatever the case may be should be
entitled to do to anyone especially
to minorities because that's where it
seems to keep coming up over and over
again so chris good morning good morning
this is what we're going to be talking
about today this is what we're going to
be dealing with because it has crossed
over with sports again and we have no
choice but to deal with it it wouldn't
seem appropriate to be talking about
who's injured
who's getting reps with the first team
we're not doing a draft today for
example but we need to deal with these
issues and understand these issues and
try to find some common ground and give
some people some understanding of where
we need to go from here and i don't know
where we need to go from here but i know
we need to talk about where we need to
go from here yeah i mean agreed about
that and yeah it's filtered over into
sports and of course it should i mean
you know i i can't even imagine
putting myself
in the shoes of a black man or an
african-american man or a man of color
in this country and having to deal with
what they have to deal with you know i
like i've talked about many times before
i've been around it had so many
experiences to get a feel for it to go
whoa that's messed up like i can't
believe that this is happening right now
and i you know again as much as i've
seen i still can't imagine being in
their shoes and going through some of
the things and growing up in some of the
environments that they've had to grow up
in so it's very unfortunate and it's
unfortunate too that yes there seems to
be you know a blind spot in our hearts
in our society a little bit about this
issue especially from white america
there's insensitivity about it and i
mean excessive force seven shots in the
back i mean excessive is a nice way of
saying that i don't you know there's
there's so many unknowns still about
this and yeah i don't understand it i
don't understand what what's happened to
where we've just become a society here
especially in some of these
african-american communities where
unarmed black man you know runs away
or whatever and we just shoot him cold
you know dead cold right there like well
i mean how about we just run him down
and beat him up or the taser or shoot
his tires out i don't know but just to
pull out a gun and shoot somebody and
end their life it's not acceptable and
it's not responsible and i can't even
imagine what some of these
african-american players are thinking
right now and of course yeah their their
their minds are in other places so it's
hard to play sports when it hits home uh
and uh it's hard to focus on sports when
you know your culture and the people
that you know look up to you are
suffering
here's
how i see it chris
the george floyd murder
as it relates to white america
a certain segment of white america woke
up
yes when the george floyd murder
happened and you know
to the extent that there are some in the
media that use the term woke derisively
you can kiss every inch of my ass yeah
that was like
because
that's what we're supposed to be we're
supposed to advance you mean like the
people that make fun of it right right
now yeah yeah oh it's quote yeah yeah
yeah right right it's
it's it's woke to talk progressive
politics let's go ahead and talk
conservative politics i mean
it's
it's hypocritical to call people woke
and i don't know when that became
something bad we should be looking for
enlightenment whatever title you want to
apply to it when george floyd was
murdered
there was a segment of white america
that said
holy crap we've been blind to this we
are no longer blind to it we no longer
accept this now here's what's going on
the jacob blake shooting is the first
test
of how many of us have realized this is
wrong
and how many of us are going to hunker
down and say he had a knife he may have
had a knife he may have done something
wrong in the past he's he's armed he's
not armed he deserved it right to try to
justify it and then the what abouts the
what abouts the what abouts that are
endless and so
we're failing the first test
because
we need to have collective outrage about
this i don't know how anyone can look at
that video
and say
well okay well we need to understand
both sides there are no both sides
he's he's savagely shot in the back as
he's getting into a vehicle there are
other ways to restrain a human being in
that instance instead of unloading your
clip into his back but mikey he's got a
criminal history he's got a criminal
background
yeah and if we can't accept
if we can't accept that there is
something inherently wrong with what
happened to jacob blake god help us you
know this is a time of plenty of
rhetoric we had the democratic national
convention last week republican national
convention this week and both sides are
saying
if the other side wins the country's
over you know what
maybe it's over anyway yeah because the
problem is we can't agree on anything
anymore right and and and it's it's even
to the point where suggesting we can't
agree on anything is something people
disagree with well i'd like to think
that anyone with a functioning brain
can look at what's going on in america
right now and say there is serious
dysfunction regardless of the cause
regardless of the root regardless of the
solution there is serious dysfunction
and when it shuts down sports
when it when it possibly temporarily
maybe permanently at least for the rest
of the season shuts down the nba that
tells you that it's a serious problem
that needs to be addressed period and
it's funny you know it's the people who
are complaining
about the nba being woke and refusing to
watch the nba or complaining the loudest
about the fact that the nba show they're
mad up your mind make up your mind you
want to watch it or not i don't you're
right either you don't care about the
nba or you do care about the nba but
don't play both sides of it and you know
that was the big news last night it was
really yesterday afternoon when it
started a perk of late the milwaukee
bucks decided to boycott
game five of their series against the
orlando magic
and technically it would have been a
forfeit but the magic said we don't
accept it we're out too and eventually
all games last night were shut down for
the nba and you know no decisions have
been made yet there's going to be an nba
board of governors meeting today the
players are going to continue to talk as
of last night there were some
conflicting reports as to whether or not
the lakers and the clippers said we're
done we're out i think the end result is
they're inclined to be out but still no
final decisions have been made but man
lebron james one of the most popular
athletes in the world leading the charge
with a tweet yesterday that included one
of chris's favorite words and i was
stunned it was jarring it was all caps
f this man we demand change sick of it
and i'll tell you what at the website at
pft yesterday we included the full
language of the tweet because in that
moment
it was so jarring and i think it was so
significant coming from lebron james
that that word had to be used i wrestled
with it i talked to my other writers
about it we decided that word had to be
used in that setting to to demonstrate
the despair to demonstrate
the the sense of helplessness and
hopelessness
that the black community has reached
where
you know
after george floyd there was a glimmer
of hope yeah things were going in the
right direction right and and then we
see what happened to jacob blake and
it's like what it's just it's forgotten
it's just forgotten and we're gonna go
back to the way we've always been and
that's not acceptable and the forfeiture
of the nba games last night not that
anyone forfeited but we lost them we
didn't get to watch them we didn't get
to enjoy them that is part of the cost
of not having a functional society when
it comes to how police interact with
black americans right period right no i
mean i mean you're spot on and of course
you know i love lebron james for you
know his ability to speak his mind be a
leader that way i mean come on the
lakers have got it going now i mean now
you look at it and go here i mean lebron
james willing to quit the nba bubble
right now when he's probably got the
best vegas odds of winning another
championship adding to his legacy i mean
i think it just shows what kind of human
being he is all together
and you know i understand athletes
across the board not wanting to practice
and do that yesterday i mean you know it
hits home certainly now here's the thing
that i have a question for mike just
going forward
what is best right like
i know the nba player is boycotting
right and i understand it and again i
can't put myself in their shoes and even
pretend to know what it feels like to be
an african-american man so i understand
they're not wanting to play practice
whatever that is but going forward
you know i just look at it and go
man i still think the best pedestal for
a guy like lebron james and kawhi
leonard and paul george and all these
other stars is to
keep playing basketball and when you're
getting the post game interview you're
but they've tried that they've done that
see you get to a point where you get
exasperated right how many times do you
have to talk about it in a press
conference before change happens and you
it's just like trying to discipline a
child yeah you try and you try and you
try and eventually got to take away the
xbox right and that's what they've done
they've taken away our xbox well you're
right listen we're not listening no they
keep trying and we're not listening no i
i get it i guess what i'm trying to say
is but put it in people's face more you
know the nba players they've been you
know taking normal what more can they do
what can they do i'm just saying as soon
as the game's over when they have the
mic in their face or one that's in the
mic the coaches because paul's done that
okay well i'm just saying they all
should do it you know what i'm saying i
know yeah i'm just saying that's what
they need to throw in america's face
that's all i'm just asking would that be
the better way to continue to shed light
on it because like we were saying we
have these people who uh i'm never
watching the nba again but then the nba
doesn't play basketball and they're
pissed that's not on tv that night and
so they're watching so i mean like i'm
just i'm just asking like lebron james
with the world championship trophy right
there like black lives matter and start
speaking about the issues of the world
that's the only thing i'm asking i'm
just curious
you know but
i hear you i hear you yeah and you know
when when coaches nba coaches far more
than nfl coaches although nfl coaches
are starting to catch up a little bit
yeah when the nba coaches started
talking about these issues it's a new
frontier the players start talking about
the issues it's a new frontier and the
whole idea of talking about the issues
is to affect change
talking does not affect change so at
some point you move on to something else
and that's where we are now there's a
business reality to this as well that we
can't ignore because it has an overlap
with the nfl because i guarantee you
even though the nba's owners are being
as supportive as they possibly can in
this fragile moment
at some point
they are going to say
guys
kind of expensive if we don't play these
games
a lot of money going away and never
coming back if we don't play these games
and you know we hate to do this but we
got a collective bargaining agreement
and there's no clause in there that
allows a wildcat strike based upon
social injustice or other unrest so at
some point we got to do this and i think
the art here for management and this is
something the nfl needs to be paying
very close attention to because they may
be confronting this this season they may
be dealing with it sooner rather than
later the games start in two weeks and
we don't know what the hell else is
going to happen we don't when the next
video of police brutality against a
black man is going to emerge
but
they better be thinking about how to
navigate these business issues because
there is a lot of money at stake there's
a lot of money at stake for the players
what happens from that perspective and i
think that's why the board of governors
will be meeting today for the nba and i
think there's there's a gentle
element of persuasion that is going to
be necessary to get these guys to commit
to finish the season because everybody
loses financially if they don't and the
players may be willing to make the
sacrifice see that's the thing we may be
at the point where players are so fed up
that they don't care about them yeah i
think i know
and and if they come to that conclusion
that's their right
but they need to understand the
potential consequences of it and you
know there are potential legal
consequences beyond just giving up the
money when you have an illegal wildcat
strike within the confines of a cba but
if they don't care they don't care what
are you gonna do to us we're fed up with
the way this society is working and we
choose not to be part of the sports
pages of the society at least for now
and that's the other question too chris
where does it lead
yeah what what is you know if it doesn't
affect change what it what what's the
point of it and do they come back no i
know and that's a scary thought because
i don't know if you know again like i
like we've talked about it already we
saw a change and things going in a
positive direction
and then
the conversation got changed to looting
and rioting and there's a lot of factors
into that that we don't have enough time
to get into where i would go
no that wasn't as
appears either you got to read some
stuff and you realize that there was
other people involved in that too but
regardless
like we're going backwards again we're
going backwards there's no doubt about
it i mean come on i mean
again i've seen more racist things again
in the last three four weeks again
online social media whatever it is it's
everywhere and i just it doesn't seem
like really
a lot of white americans want to really
deal with this or take it head-on or
really learn from it and so many judge
from ten thousand feet above where i
just feel like and i even know because i
have certain friends who have made
comments and you know i always have to
bring them back to but like yeah you've
you've never been around an
african-american
guy in your life you know an exten for
an extensive period of time you've never
gone home with any of these guys and
seen how they lived and what it's all
about and the struggles they go through
and the desperation they have to you
know constantly live with to just
survive their lives so many of the times
and it just seems like a part of our
society's numb to that and doesn't care
and it's just uh it's it's
it's unfortunate i don't understand it
and i just it's crazy that was 2020 and
we're going the wrong direction
nfl players are taking notice of what's
going on they are approving of what the
nba players have done
and
rightfully so
i thought jerry jones like right away
yesterday when this went down because we
talked about it yesterday and then went
oh this is going to you know instigate
the fires again right i mean don terry
po is going to be more passionate about
kneeling once again after something like
this
and and and it's a potentially bigger
fire
than cowboys players defying jerry jones
preferences at this point definitely and
it's amazing how how different the
context is chris in just 24 hours now
the question is
will there be
the possibility of players refusing to
play
based upon reaction to what the nba has
done based upon whatever the nba does
going forward based upon the next
incident and the fact that we had one in
may we have one in august i think it's
naive to assume there's gonna be another
one
between august and february when the
super bowl rolls around what will nfl
teams do what will nfl players do
in response to it earlier this week the
lions were actually the first
tangible example of sports standing up
right in response to the shooting of
jacob blake canceling practice and
speaking to reporters and when i saw the
canceled practice on tuesday my first
thought was they had a covet outbreak or
another batch of false positives from
that lab in new jersey they still don't
know how in the hell they got 77 false
positives but no they shut down practice
because of what happened to jacob blake
washington canceling their practice for
today at fedex field because of social
justice issues washington has other
issues we're going to be discussing
later in the show but they decided from
the team perspective they're going to
talk about racism and social injustice
in lieu of going to fedex field and
getting themselves ready for the stadium
or for the season rather in a preseason
with no games yeah with no joint
practices no opportunity to truly
prepare they're giving up an opportunity
to prepare now they'll postpone it
they'll do it later but the fact that
they're taking a day in this crazy
upside down year chris
to give up a day of practice a
significant day of practice that would
be very useful to getting ready for week
one
that tells me that they are taking it
seriously and they're doing what they
need to do to make sure that the players
feel like they're being heard internally
and that
they just have a general sense there's
some path to action that can be
meaningful right right well yeah i mean
i think it's it's great on some of these
nfl teams part to
you know halt all football things for
you know whatever how however long it is
temporary a few days whatever it is
guys heads aren't in the right place
their hearts aren't in the right place
it's hard to go out and have a good
practice and really accomplish something
worthwhile if you're sitting there
thinking about you know your hometown or
the injustices of the world and gosh
they have to be sad and have heavy
hearts that way i mean how can you not
so i look at that and i think the
biggest thing to me
is i think the nfl coaches are woke and
i mean that in a good way i do i think
you know the events of the last few
months have really opened their eyes
even to a greater degree you know i
think nfl coaches were very aware of
social injustice but their nfl coaches
and their coach and their coach and
their coach and the coach and here's an
x here's an o and they're just obsessed
with their job sometimes where they
don't sit back and like actually you
know take a deep breath and go what's
going on in the world today i think they
got that this year a little bit and i
think it's made the coaches certainly
more sensitive to the african-american
players and black players uncertain on
teams because they realize like it's
it's hitting home to them and they
realize this is a real struggle and it's
bothering them as a culture a community
and they're trying to heal and hear them
and you know again like you said the nfl
needs to figure out something right now
we got to go next level nfl it's got to
go next level with whatever that is you
know
donations of money paying you know
tributes what i don't know what that is
but but they better be ready to make the
players somewhat happy and feeling
comfortable
and getting this conversation back on
track and moving in the right direction
where like i said it seems like it's
going in the wrong direction right now
again
well the first and most obvious thing to
revisit what we said yesterday the
commissioner can
tell jerry jones in very public and no
uncertain terms do not interfere with
the rights of players to express
themselves during the national anthem i
asked the league yesterday for a comment
on jerry jones apparent effort to thread
the needle and compromise with players
and get them to not kneel for the anthem
and the league had no comment which
doesn't give me a whole lot of faith
that needle hole just got smaller though
just to thread that it got a lot smaller
man
and and the camel got a lot fatter right
uh that's for damn sure uh pete carroll
the seahawks head coach yesterday after
a mock game that was held
before which the anthem was played and
multiple members of the team sat during
the anthem pete carroll was asked about
the
uh the current atmosphere the current
climate and where it could lead for the
nfl here's some of what pete had to say
you know i heard heard doc rivers
talking today and and uh
doctor did a great job of and it's this
is just ridiculous that we're putting up
this is i can't even imagine that this
continues to happen
how i don't know how somebody could ever
do that under the circumstances and the
awareness that everybody should have
right now but it continues to happen so
it continues to be a real problem and uh
there's a lot of problems and but that's
just one of the ones that just jumps out
at us and so um i really applaud those
guys for for taking the night and uh but
that we all know that's not enough
that's just a statement and the the
what is important and everybody that's
involved knows it's what we do about it
and what we keep doing to straighten
things out and get things right
this whole thing is it's ridiculous and
anybody that doesn't recognize that just
isn't paying attention and so uh
yeah we're on it too does it seem
possible an nfl team would not take the
field or your team wouldn't take the
field because of this
uh you know
anything's possible i i mentioned to the
players this is the year
it's the protest season you know
it's a season of protest and and uh
so we'll you know we'll handle ourselves
as we do and um
but it's this is this is a protest that
doesn't have an end to it until until
all the problems go away
well
that's a hell of a goal and i don't know
how realistic it is but but i think
that's what the players want to see they
want to see that they're being heard
yeah and that they're not being
dismissed that it's not just lip service
yeah we hear you we're taking care of
that well what what are you doing right
about it yeah what's your plan of action
so what are we doing right thing yeah no
no no
go higher why don't yes right i know
you're right right yeah every owner in
the nfl other than shot khan
and kim pagula co-owner of the bills
shad khan owner of the jaguars every
other owner white
what is the nfl collectively going to do
about this now look the nfl's made a
push for increased voter registration
and and then that's good that's one
tangible thing but i feel like this
moment calls out for something more and
it needs to be a loud voice it needs to
be a unified voice and it needs to be
something that shows it's not just
saying what needs to be said to check
the box and get the players to not walk
out and you know pete carroll won't
close the door on the possibility of a
walkout and chris on top of everything
else we are going to be monitoring as
this season unfolds that ever present
risk of a coven 19 outbreak
that there's an ever-present risk now
that something will happen
that will cause players the night before
a game the day of a game
or right up until kickoff to say
we're not doing it yeah we will not play
we refuse to take the field under these
circumstances sports are a reward for a
functional society and we are currently
not functional no we are not we are
totally dysfunctional the most
dysfunctional i've seen in my lifetime
and i know you know i'm about to be 40
and all that and haven't been around all
that long but this clearly takes the
cake and i think it is a real
possibility i mean of course it is in a
place like seattle too i mean pete
carroll he can understand of course it's
hit home up there that's been a real
issue in the city of seattle you know
portland oregon still going on there so
that hits home to the football players
and pete carroll you know the one thing
we've seen with his teams is he gets
guys that are not afraid to speak their
mind that are pretty smart you know well
thought out deep thinkers who bring out
these societal issues at times and yeah
they're going to confront them and he's
got the type of team and guys that are
you know
outside the box thinkers and you know
just that type of guy to where they
would be the type of team that would say
you know screw off we might not play
this weekend or threaten that or not
play or have some sort of really
creative boycott because they have a
leader like pete carroll too who doesn't
squash that an ownership that doesn't
squash that and i respect that and then
this is the other thing that bothers me
mike too much i hear this right now and
i've even had some friends say this to
me and it's pissed me off like where
they've gone
you know
pete carroll just has to say that he
just has to say that because he's in a
he's in a locker room with all these
black people and i've had people
make comments to me like that oh you
just have to say that about politics or
this issue because you're on tv do the
networks make you say this what like get
the hell out of here no this is how i
feel this is really how i feel i'm not
pressured into this by anything i've
seen it i witness it there's issues with
white america and it has to be fixed
that's all there is to it and they're
blinded by it and their ignorance
continues to just you know
hurt the situation and this like blind
eye towards it is doing nobody any any
good
and it's amazing to me that people would
be that cynical about an issue that is
so fundamental
to our fundamental right to life
right
that that people would think there's
anything other than a genuine care for
our fellow human beings we go back to
the original founding documents we
talked about this extensively after
george floyd was killed the right to
life liberty in the pursuit of happiness
it applies to everyone everyone is
included in that there should not be
a summary execution which is what george
floyd's murder was which is what almost
happened to jacob blake and his life is
forever changed even if he fully
recovers because he's paralyzed from the
waist down and as they've said it's
going to take a miracle to repair him so
that that's what's stunning to me and
i i think a lot of this chris
a lot of the concern that the players
have
isn't necessarily for them it's for
their children yes exactly for their
nieces and nephews for the next
generation and this is i think the the
message that i would have for anyone out
there who is white
who doesn't quite get it
if you have a child
if you have a niece if you have a nephew
if you have anyone under the age of 18
that you love and care about friend god
child anyone
that that act of sending them out to the
world is is terrifying
so think of those kids
and then pretend they're black
and think about how you'd feel then
sending those children out into
this world that we currently inhabit
we'll continue the discussion when we
return pft live back after this
[Music]
you